ahora ya sabemos un poquito de raíces
cuadradas por ejemplo nosotros ya
sabemos que 7 al cuadrado es 49 y como
ya sabemos sobre raíces cuadradas
podemos garantizar que 7 es la raíz
cuadrada de 49 verdad entonces si nos
fijamos muy bien lo que podríamos ver es
que elevaría al cuadrado esencialmente
lo que hace es cancelar la raíz por
ejemplo si nosotros tenemos raíz
cuadrada de 49 que 7 y lo elevamos al
cuadrado esto sería 7 al cuadrado pero
ya sabemos que es 49 verdad entonces lo
que hizo elevar al cuadrado a esta raíz
cuadrada fue simplemente cancelar la
verdad y esto por supuesto funciona para
cualquier número no solo para 49 si
nosotros tenemos
y digamos que a x le queremos sacar su
raíz cuadrada y luego lo elevamos al
cuadrado el cuadrado cancela la raíz
cuadrada verdad entonces simplemente
tenemos el número x muy bien ahora bien
esto es muy importante que observemos
ahora porque x no puede ser cualquier
número nosotros necesitamos para poder
calcular una raíz cuadrada que ese
número sea no negativo verdad porque si
no hay un número que multiplicado por sí
mismo nos dé un número negativo verdad
bueno al menos por ahora porque te darás
cuenta a medida que avances en tu
carrera matemática que hay otro tipo de
números que son los números imaginarios
y que si podrían hacer que digamos al
elevar los al cuadrado nos dé cosas
negativas pero por ahora no verdad no
hay un número que al elevarlo al
cuadrado nos dé algo negativo al elevar
al cuadrado un número siempre nos dan
cosas positivas verdad
0 o positiva verdad entonces el enfoque
de este vídeo no era hacer un repaso de
la raíz cuadrada verdad sino ahora lo
que vamos a ver es qué es la raíz cúbica
y vamos a ver cómo es que esto se
relaciona un poquito con geometría
veamos diga digamos que tenemos un
cuadrado vamos a empezar con el caso del
cuadrado digamos que tenemos un cuadrado
y de que este cuadrado tiene de lado 7
verdad y todos sus lados miden 7
entonces si nosotros nos preguntamos
cuánto mide el área o cuál es cuál es el
área de este cuadrado pues simplemente
tendríamos que multiplicar 7 por 7
verdad que es más que poner 49 voy a
poner 7
al cuadrado que 7 por 7 verdad y de
hecho podríamos haber iniciado del lado
contrario imaginemos por ahora que
tenemos un cuadrado también
aunque yo al menos un intento de
cuadrado digamos que todo que tome de
igual ok y digamos que este cuadrado
tiene como área digamos tiene x unidades
de área muy bien la pregunta sería
cuánto mide cada uno de sus lados verdad
entonces tendríamos que pensar en un
número que multiplicado por sí mismo dos
veces nos dé x y ese número ya sabemos
que es la raíz cuadrada de xy entonces
aquí ya te estás dando cuenta de dónde
viene el concepto de raíz cuadrada o de
por qué hay que porque se dice que
elevamos al cuadrado verdad entonces
ahora no lo pensemos únicamente como un
cuadrado sino vamos a verlo ahora en un
cubo
ahí tenemos nuestra tapa superior del
cubo ok ahora vamos a poner las paredes
laterales de este
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos este cubo
y por supuesto sabemos que los cubos
tienen siempre la misma y tienen las
mismas dimensiones verdad tienen lo
mismo de largo lo mismo de alto y lo
mismo de profundidad en este caso vamos
a decir que vale 2 ok entonces si nos
preguntamos cuál es el volumen de este
cubo simplemente tenemos que multiplicar
2 x 2 por 2 y esto nos da 8 verdad bueno
debería poner antes de decir que es 8
debería poner que es 2 al cubo verdad y
ahora ya sabes por qué se le dice que le
vamos al cual el número 2 verdad
entonces esto sabemos que es 8 muy bien
entonces qué pasaría ahora si lo
planteamos al revés imaginemos que
tenemos
y un cubo también
nuestro cubo
y como siempre vamos a imaginar que si
tiene todas las mismas dimensiones y
digamos ahora que el volumen de este
cubo es 8
aunque digamos que el volumen es 8 la
pregunta sería cuáles son sus
dimensiones y por supuesto sus
dimensiones son desconocidas pero
sabemos que todas que todas son iguales
verdad digamos este sería x la altura
sería x la profundidad sería x muy bien
entonces lo que sabemos es que al
multiplicar x por x por x nos da 8 pero
x por x por x es x al cubo y eso tiene
que darnos 8 o bien otra forma de
representarlo es utilizando radicales
verdad podríamos decir que x es la raíz
cúbica de 8 y para decir o indicar que
es una raíz cúbica ponemos aquí un
número 3
esta es la forma de representar las
raíces cúbicas y tú dirás oye pues es
muy parecido a la raíz cuadrada porque
la raíz cuadrada no llevaba por ejemplo
12 de este lado y en realidad es que se
podría poner pero en en realidad es un
digamos es una notación que resulta
redundante cuando no se pone el 2
estamos pensando inmediatamente en raíz
cuadrada muy bien entonces en resumen x
este número x es el número tal que al
elevarlo al cubo nos da 8 verdad que en
este caso de este cubo valdría 2 vamos a
ver otros ejemplos vamos a ver otros
ejemplos digamos que tenemos que
calcular la raíz cúbica de 27 muy bien
tenemos que calcular la raíz cúbica de
27 este es nuestro número x es decir es
lo mismo que encontrar un número x que
al elevarlo al cubo multiplicarlo
consigo mismo tres veces nos da 27
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar en
todos los números podríamos ver que x es
igual a 3 verdad x 3 es nuestra solución
porque 3 x 3 ó 9 y 9 por 3 son 27
ahora bien tú podrías preguntarte
podríamos escribir la raíz cúbica de
menos 64 ok eso es una pregunta válida
nosotros vimos que para el caso de la
raíz cuadrada el número que iba dentro
del radical tenía que ser no negativo es
decir tenía que ser cero o algo positivo
verdad pero por ejemplo tendría sentido
pensar en la raíz cúbica de menos 64 es
decir podríamos encontrar un número x un
número x tal que al elevarlo al cubo nos
dé menos 64 y la respuesta es que si por
ejemplo pensemos en menos 4 multiplicado
consigo mismo
tres veces verdad entonces menos cuatro
por menos cuatro ahí nos da más y cuatro
por cuatro son 16 y ahora 16 por menos 4
nos da menos y 16 por 4 nos da 64 verdad
entonces nuestro resultado es menos 64
si tomamos x igual a
-4 entonces como podemos observar si se
pueden tomar raíces cúbicas de números
negativos verdad y por supuesto las
raíces cúbicas no son el único tipo de
raíces que existen podríamos seguir
calculando la raíz cuarta o la raíz
quinta o la raíz décima o centésima o lo
que se nos ocurra verdad hay muchos
tipos de raíces pero eso lo dejaremos
para después muy bien ahora lo que hemos
visto son ejemplos muy fáciles pero qué
pasaría así por ejemplo nos piden
calcular la raíz cúbica raíz cúbica de
125 muy bien qué pasaría si nos piden
calcular la raíz cúbica de 125 y una
forma fácil de tratar de encontrar esta
raíz es factor izando en su
descomposición en números primos al
número 125 por ejemplo este es
por 25 verdad y luego el 25 lo podemos
ver como 5 por 5 entonces al final 125
es sí
al cubo verdad y si nosotros queremos
calcular la raíz cúbica de 5 al cubo
esto simplemente es 5 verdad entonces
esta forma este es un método fácil para
encontrar raíces cúbicas pero si tenemos
un número muy muy grande no hay un
método eficiente para calcularlo ni
siquiera existe un método eficiente para
calcular la raíz cuadrada